The Intermediate Value Theorem gives us some really fundamental information
then, about how to find zeros in curves without breaks in them. We just need to
look for regions of the graph where y values switch from being positive to
being negative, or from being negative to being positive. In either case, the
curve must have at least one x intercept somewhere in that region that we're
looking at. This is pretty general information, though. And the intermediate
value theorem can actually help us even more. In fact, Athena used it on the
train in a very clever way. One day, Athena needed to catch the train in
Mountain View. She had been visiting the Udacity office for the afternoon. Now,
to find out what time her train would leave, she called her brother, Nicos. All
he could tell her was that the train would come to Mountain View sometime
between 4pm and 6pm. This information wasn't quite accurate enough for Athena.
She wanted to be able to plan her afternoon a bit more precisely. So she looked
up the schedule for the train. Much to Athena's disappointment, somehow, the
one departure time that was missing from the train schedule was the time that
the train would leave Mountain View. We have the times for every other stop
listed, and the stops are written in order here, just like we saw on the map
earlier. Staring in San Jose and then moving north along the track. Based on
this schedule, Athena knows a window of time within which the train will leave
from Mountain View. What is that window?